bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nobile io sono quello che ogni
tanto si veste recentemente è piaciuto
un sacco il primo episodio di lo faresti
con le vostre domande
ho deciso quindi di fare l'episodio
number two nel caso non lo conoscete
ve lo spiego veloce me ha comunque ho
notato che nonostante l'outfit le calze
vabbè tanto non si vedono
stavo dicendo consiste nel mettere due
opzioni una esclude l'altra e questa
cosa scrivete nelle storie di instagram
i fatti qua vedrete la domanda in
questione infatti qua vedrete le opzioni
in questione che l'avete scritto e
proprio voi quindi ragazzi provate a
scrivere un'e qua sotto nei commenti se
li mette qualcosa oppure la prossima
volta che fare una sola di chi starà
meglio pescherà un po da entrambe quindi
let's go alessia mi chiede preferiresti
stare senza il computer o senza il
telefono allo ragazzi io preferirei
stare senza telefono perché lo dico
sempre questo in realtà al telefono ci
asciugano un po la vita nel senso che
una volta che uno inizia spippolare sul
telefono uno speculare nel senso andare
a fare cose non quello che pensate voi
mangia e quindi ci porta via tanto tempo
quando invece potremo goderci il momento
per avere un liberec i nokia 3.300
qualcosa invece dell'iphone però per
lavoro me lo devo tenere se non fosse
per lavoro c'è un miniset orribile se
non fosse per lavoro
avrei quello quindi il computer
l'utilizzo per i video e senza il
telefono preferiresti bere solo l'acqua
del water per tutta la vita o mangiare
terra per tutta la vita
allora ragazzi ovviamente sceglierei
bere l'acqua del vate ma per un motivo
molto semplice perché l'acqua del water
se il batter è completamente pulito cioè
allora io mi compro battere lo mettono
lo uso mai tiri lo show quale si riempie
ma il battere pulito come se prendessi
l'acqua dal lavandino tappato quindi se
non ci caghi dentro succede niente se il
vate re pulito quindi compro batterlo
metto al posto del lavandino e ogni
volta e rovere vado li tirò il successo
che cacchio di sicuro non mangio la
terra preferiresti vivere ricco ma da
solo tutta la vita oppure povero ma
insieme alla donna che ami sono
sociopatico quindi vivrei da solo
comunque da povero quindi fammi almeno
essere ricco e non rompere le palle per
vedere sti essere protagonista di autras
toti e tweet la domanda qua e un po
sottovalutata perché tutti di base ci
vien da dire è più che comunque altre
però come non se la passa proprio
benissimo quello di happy meals quelli
di f non sa passano proprio bene almeno
con auto su una possibilità ce l'hai
anche questa premessa inserì interno di
faul guys al litro yepes credo anzi sono
sicuro fall guys perché for guys alla
fine non muori cioè nel senso vede anche
nel gioco di focali se proprio ci sono
le cose sono proprio anti
infortunistiche proprio io vorrei fare
folger anzi vorrei fare il mio sogno nel
cassetto era fare takeshi's castle
sempre chiesto mannaggia il cacchio non
sono mai riuscito perché poi in giappone
lo citavano mille anni fa però mamma mia
che bello sarebbe pare ha circa dunque
fall guys subito ma in ballo farei
adesso vestito così preferiresti essere
immortale un miliardo ma ragazzi ma
veramente ancora pensate che
avere il successo va immortale ma tutta
la vita ma state scherzando la vita nel
senso ovvero senza parrucca feriti
essere bello ma stupido abruzzo ma
intelligenze non vedo perché io che sono
bello intelligente debba rispondere a
questa domanda finessi dormire per
sempre o non dormire mai in realtà
questa qua e una domanda basta
intelligente perché a dormire secondo me
è una perdita di tempo io dormo tanto dr
motor a notte perché sono solo uno
zombie ma non vorrei dormire se vi
dicessero tu puoi non dormire non ti
stanchi mai e vivi tranquillo per tu non
hai bisogno di dormire subito bellissima
cover e il telefono non si scarica e
veramente bello il problema è che io
seedorf a 7 ore invece di 8 è solo un
rincoglionito per quello a scuola andavo
anche male poi ci scherzate ma in realtà
era perché non riuscivo a dormire o
preferiti solo mangiare salato per tutta
la vita
ho solo dolce allora io di base
preferisco il dolce però il dolce mi
stanca subito cioè nel senso se io
mangio una crepa la nutella ad esempio
poi dopo ciò ha solo a vederne un'altra
ho la nausea però nel momento in cui la
maggior benissimo in breve sul momento
sceglierei dolce ma se dovessi scegliere
per tutta la vita salato se dovrò più
ingenui prevedessi essere bello ma
puzzolente o essere brutto ma profumato
ragazzi io vi dico questa cosa vedo
alcuni di voi già sanno chi mi ha
incontrato i raduni losappio questo
problema che non è un problema di quei
problemi della vita dove in realtà e ti
serve io non puzzo ok ma io non posso
perché secondo me mi manca della roby
mancano dei gunners degli ormoni non so
mi manca nella delle ghiandole non ne ho
idea io comunque non puzzo sudo quando
horror è però non posso quindi già che
non puzza mi manca solo essere bello ma
la finiamo dai la finiamo la finiamo
finiamo preferiresti poter avere
l'aspetto che vuoi una volta su due o
cambiarlo tutte le volte che vuoi ma
senza a sceglierlo adorate immaginati
che io posso cambiare l'aspetto così
senza mai sceglie qui non sai mai chi ti
trasformi vado la sera da selena gomez
di busso alla porta e nel momento in cui
apre la porta io cam e mi trasformo in
lino banfi o questa questa è
difficilissima preferiresti viaggiare
gratuitamente o mangiare tutto quello
che vuoi gratuitamente questa è
veramente bene e pesa non lo so non lo
so perché
mamma mia questa è veramente difficile
secondo me il via già allora attualmente
io spendo più di cibo che di viaggi ok
quindi mi converrebbe scegliere il cibo
però è anche vero che se posso viaggiare
gratuitamente dovunque voglio scelgo la
stanza top d'albergo 10mila euro a notte
e ci sto una settimana cioè mi conviene
molto di più viaggiare gratuitamente
mangiare gratuitamente però per il mio
stile di vita attuale quindi senza
modificare quello che il mio stile di
vita sarebbe conveniente per me mangiare
gratuitamente perché spendono di finch i
voli in viaggi il cibo e direi di
chiudere con l'ultima che è la migliore
di tutte preferiresti essere gerry
scotti o carlo conti io non me ne voglia
il buon carlo però un depo sempre avuto
un debole per jerry infatti questa
outfit è ispirato a lui
spero che generi un giorno mi noti mi
dica lei lorenzo ti va di fare come una
puntata di chi vuol essere milionario in
modo tale da poter mostrare pubblico che
ho fatto le elementari e rispondere ad
almeno la prima domanda giusta se ci
riesco comunque per adesso io finisco
qua questo video è sempre bello fare le
preferenze vostre domande ragazzi
scrivete nel qua sotto
ma seguitemi anche mi raccomando su
instagram perché quando registro un
video e del genere in genere guardo
entrambe le cose e come sempre ragazzi
se vi sia piaciuto lasciato un mi piace
iscrivetevi al canale e noi ci rivediamo
come sempre ad un fronte omino bella
ragazza
[Musica]